good afternoon and welcome to the
Atlanta Georgia remotely I think this is
a phenomenal technology and I appreciate
all of you out there with me and
spending the next hour with me talk
about training my name is Sean Kaufman
I'm the director of training programs at
Emory University also a the president
and co-founder of behavioral based
improvement solutions which really is a
a business designed to deliver
behavioral based training programs for
individuals who work in laboratory
environments primarily high containment
laboratory environments for the last 10
years I've been involved in several
types of programs teaching folks to work
safely in lab environments and one of
the most important audiences that I can
think of or the laboratory animal
science folks because as you compare
them with typical scientists who may
find themselves working at biosafety
cabinets or just with a little bit of a
particular pathogen laboratory animal
science folks are working with animals
and these animals are unpredictable and
could be shedding a lot of the pathogens
that we're working with and typically
what we see is these animal care staff
and the laboratory animal folks are some
of the most unprepared individuals for
working in a laboratory environment so
again I want to thank all of you for the
opportunity to share some of my ideas
and strategies and thoughts on how you
can implement safe and effective
training and I hope that this program is
beneficial I know that some of you may
have questions and what I'd like to do
is I'd like for you to feel free to
enter those questions at any time and so
please if you have any questions at any
time to enter them but what we're going
to do is we're going to wait to the very
end to actually answer them so I don't
want you to forget your questions so if
you have it go ahead and type it in and
send it and then what we'll do at the
end is we'll see if we can address the
questions moving forward so again thank
you and I'd like to go ahead and get
started because I can talk all day about
training and the reality is I only
an hour with you guys at this point one
of the things I'd like to start out with
specifically to this program is really
defining what training is and really in
essence what it isn't a lot of folks
like to use the word training kind of
synonymously with a lot of other things
so for example if I go into a classroom
and I sit and watch a PowerPoint people
will call that training you have the
blood-borne pathogen training which is
you know something that folks have to
work or go through almost an annual
basis with OSHA and they have to sit and
watch the same slides over and over
again if you're sitting on your butt and
you're watching slides and you're
actually listening to a presentation
that's going to increase your overall
awareness very similar to what I'm doing
today that is not a training program
that actually is an awareness building
program so when I talk about training
today I'm not going to be talking about
programs that you know that build
awareness I'm gonna be talking about
programs that actually focus on
okay I'm on the phone looks like I
apologize for dropping off I don't know
what what has happened here um Tracy
want to help me my back online oh okay
sorry about that okay so I apologize
folks so if I'm not able to teach
someone how to swim with PowerPoint then
in essence is it's not training if we
were to take for example the child put
them in front of a PowerPoint and teach
them how to swim with a PowerPoint and
then throw them in the swimming pool our
training program would be labeled as
very ineffective and and probably not
very conducive for teaching folks how to
swim the other thing that I'd like to
talk about is this aspect of an expert
type training so what we call education
and so if I am a swimmer and I've
already been swimming for quite some
time and we're going to review a video
of my technique and try to tweak certain
things that I do that is really an
education aspect based on my experience
so for this presentation what we're
going to be dealing with and what we're
going to be talking about is training as
a as building a skill what what type of
skills the folks working in laboratories
especially with animals need to acquire
and how do they need to acquire those to
be safe with the work that they do
another thing that I really want to
focus on too is this sense of purpose of
training you know the worst thing you
can ever do for a trainer is actually
make a training program mandatory and if
I had poles out there I'd probably ask
you guys how many of you have been
forced to come to this session today
that's the worst thing that you can
actually make someone do is to attend a
training program because if you're
making someone come into a program to
learn a skill and they're not wanting to
learn that skill then that puts a
tremendous burden on the trainer so if
your purpose of training is to punish
someone or to remain in compliance
that's another you know I'm going to
train folks so that I remain in
compliance and that's your sole purpose
then I would say that your training
programs are actually starting off on a
outside and on a bad note because the
purpose of training really is an
investment in an individual not only in
their professional aspects but also
their personal aspects because their
learning skills they can not only apply
at the office that they're also applying
it at home as well so when you look at
training training should be a process it
shouldn't be a one-time shot rather a
vaccine that's repeated as you as you go
on so the purpose of training is to
invest in an individual to increase
skill to fine-tune that skill and really
in essence to verify and make sure that
someone is capable of working safely and
doing what it is we're asking to do in
the laboratory environment the next
slide is kind of comical I'm you know my
mug shot there because no matter what
you do with me and especially if you you
take a look at a recipe card and I would
like to replace that as look if I'm an
animal care staff work or if I'm working
with animals in the laboratory
environment and you give me a set of
SOPs and in this case as the example
would say really in essence a a book of
recipes which are standard operating
procedures which I like to call standard
operating behaviors no matter what you
do if you don't mentor me if you don't
invest in any kind of training with me
you will never make me as good as the
chef is so just because you give me a
book of Martha Stewart recipes does not
and will not ever make me Martha Stewart
it simply won't work and if I were to
give all of you a recipe card from
Martha Stewart and have you cook the
same thing off that recipe card you
would have inconsistent outcomes meaning
all of you would bring back something
that looked different tastes a different
smell different and even though it was
the same exact recipe the outcomes would
be a variable and that's something in a
laboratory environment that we cannot
afford to have so the reality is is when
you look at behavioral based training or
you look at any type of training program
you're really trying to minimize variety
in the overall outcome and minimizing
that variety means that you will achieve
safety because it's in the variable
outcomes
the varied operating procedures that
accidents and incidents happen and that
that preventable issues can can actually
be stopped or minimized if you look at
the the philosophy that I've used over
the last ten years in training we use a
concept called plans plus behaviors
equals outcomes now I think it's
inherent that no one wakes up in the
morning whether they are a scientist or
laboratory animal care technician or
anybody for that matter that wakes up in
the morning and says I think today is
gonna be my last day at work and I'm
gonna go to work and do something stupid
which is going to end up killing me or
other people I don't I don't think that
so I think the general outcome is fairly
consistent we all want to go to work we
want to be safe at work and we want to
make sure that what we do at work stays
at work and it does not come home with
us I think that's inherent I think to
assume otherwise is you know insulting
at times to folks who work in laboratory
environment but here's the issue that I
have so many folks think that a written
plan is going to produce that safe
outcome that if I can just write a plan
give that person a plan
have them sign that plan so they're
signing the plan and and then let them
go work we have a problem
that does not produce consistent
outcomes and in fact it doesn't even
verify that the individual is capable of
working safely in a laboratory
environment in order for us to bridge
plans and outcomes in order for us to
ensure that a plan does produce the
outcome we're looking for we have
several things that we have to do the
first thing we've got to do is take a
look at the plan so many plans today are
written in one language and there are so
many people who work in the lab that
come from a variety of different
countries
can you speak different languages if the
SOPs that are written for that
laboratory environment are not written
in a language that everybody understands
then we've got a problem the next
problem is when we use jargon words so
for example if I want someone to dawn or
Dolf equivalent with equivalently in
cooking I may ask somebody to whip
beaten whip or beat an egg or even in
essence coddle an egg
these things are culinary terms and
unless you have experience in the in the
cook industry you probably may not be
able to differentiate whipping and
beating and coddling an egg just like if
you don't have much experience in lab
industry donning and doffing may be in
terms that you were unfamiliar with and
you then therefore cannot follow the SOP
because the terminology is not very
clear last but not least and this is an
interesting exercise if you have a piece
of paper in front of you I'd like for
you to follow a quick and brief SOP and
that SOP is I'd like for you to fold
that piece of paper in half eight times
and what you will find if you go ahead
and try and fold that piece paper in
half eight times as proven on
Mythbusters by the way that the only
number that you can fold is seven times
no matter how big this sheet of paper is
so even though the reality is you cannot
fold a piece of paper eight times it
doesn't mean that I can't write that as
an SOP and so a lot of SOPs are actually
written in a manner that are that that
that makes it physically impossible for
people to follow so when we take a look
at our SOPs we first have to take a look
at well are the plans understandable
language wise understandable from a
jargon aspect and also actually
physically possible if we have plans
that are that way we then move to the
next level
which is really looking at validity and
making sure that what the author is
saying is actually what is demonstrated
by the person reading those words so for
example if I say put your hand over your
head and then I look around the room and
there's inconsistencies because there
would be someone raised or left someone
raises the right so I would have their
hands up in the air someone have their
hands over their head the reality is is
that until I give those words that
produce ultimate consistency around all
the people in the room my SOP has not
validated okay so plans can't just be
written and then hand it to someone and
say go do it typically the
author of the SOP takes it very personal
when SOPs are not being followed when in
reality typically if SOPs aren't being
followed and it is solely an SOP issue
it's typically the SOP that needs to be
changed and not the individual if you
look at behavior I want you to imagine
someone walking down the street and as
they walk down the street they fall into
a pit and in this pit is about ten feet
of water
there's no way out and there's a great
white shark swimming in that water of
course the person who falls in that pit
would panic a little bit
once they gathered them themselves they
would actually scream for help now if I
came over and looked down to that pit
and I said that looks like a pretty big
risk down there the individual typically
look at you and say well no doc can you
please help me and I would say well it
would be a great benefit if you got out
of that pit and the person would then
say yeah please help me now if at that
point I chose to walk away and I didn't
see that person until a week later and
they have lost their arm as a result of
that shark attack they probably would
not have very nice things to say to me
they probably beat me with the other arm
that they have but the reality is this
most trainings out there do just that
they discuss risk and benefit and that's
the awareness aspect that's what you can
do during PowerPoint you know that shark
is a big risk it would be a great
benefit if you got away from the shore
most of those awareness training
programs are things that are more
common-sense like you know hey we have a
risk in the lab and it would be a
benefit if you followed the SOP it's
when you get to the third one which is
skills and that's like me throwing a
rope down to the person and the pit but
not holding onto the other end of it
giving someone about safety cabinet or
animal cages or any type of equipment
without any type of training is like
throwing a rope and not holding the end
of it it's useless you might as well
with the shark with it and then if you
look at the skills after that you look
at the skills so that's the resources if
you look at skills
you basically have to give somebody time
to practice that SOP until they feel
comfortable and they
like that SOP is actually beneficial so
when you look at behaviors you have to
have five things to ensure an SOP or a
sustained behavior occurs the first
people have to understand the risk they
face the second they have to understand
the benefit the third they have to have
the resources to follow the SOP the
fourth they have to have the skills and
last but not least they have to have the
belief in themselves that they can not
only follow the SOP but that the SOP
actually makes a difference when you
look at your overall outcome it should
be measurable in time and overall
outcome but when we talk about plans +
behaviors equals outcomes the reality of
it is training is absolutely critical
because it is the bridge between the
plan and the outcome and if we don't
have effective training programs then
our outcomes are at risk and that's the
key point with this slide now many of
you out there probably run your training
programs I know there's a lot of folks
that are very experienced in training
now I will openly and candidly say that
you know look all trainers are people
but not all people are trainers the
reality is this many of you have tried
several types of training programs and
are not getting the results that you
want and so if that's the case I love to
turn to Albert Einstein who says look
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting different
results
the difference between a lesson learned
and a lesson ignored is change and I
listen I I can feel for those folks who
are out there that have a million things
to do and training has been thrown on
them as an additional responsibility
that puts you in a very very bad place
and I would argue that there are some
there are some phenomenal training
options out there whether you can engage
a third party who can customize your
training solutions and actually deliver
a very engaging up-to-date training
program for you and your organization I
would you know I would challenge you to
look for those for those organizations
but the reality is this if training is
thing on your priority list and you're a
trainer that's going to be tough because
let me tell you if it's a last thing on
your list when you go to deliver it
it'll probably be the last thing on the
people who are receiving it's list as
well it's it's kind of one of those
things where if you were born giving a
training program then the people in the
audience are going to be bored
receiving it as well so if you are not
seeing the results that you want then it
is time for you to make a change and
let's take a look at what some of those
things that you can actually do as a
result of changing your your training
program the first thing that I want to
talk about is is is behavior being a you
know kind of a two-edged sword and this
is again a very important component for
training training kind of helps us
maintain that balance if you are someone
who behaves you know so let's say you're
someone who changes animal cages on a
daily basis or you're doing the
cropsey's on a daily basis or you're
doing you know animal care & husbandry
on a daily basis let's say that you're
someone who does something at a high
frequency well you are at a risk a very
very big risk of becoming very very
complacent and what it is that you're
doing and not only complacent and I'm
not gonna say arrogant but I am going to
say stubborn meaning you develop a habit
in a ritual that you like to use and
anybody who comes in with something
different or an observation that maybe a
critique you can become a little
defensive training is is something that
will continuously challenge individuals
and challenge complacency by giving them
something new something they're not
thinking about something out of the
ordinary and also possibly teaching new
ways of doing the things that folks are
doing on a day-to-day and daily basis
that is a serious risk complacency is a
is a serious risk I want you to think
about the first day that you ever did
what did you do today the very first day
you had a great attitude because you
really wanted to demonstrate your skills
and capabilities you were paying
attention to everything around you your
eyes were wide open either it's probably
a little bit of an adrenaline rush
you were learning something new and as
time has gone by you've gotten bored
maybe you're doing it over and over
again you you wish that there were other
things that you could be doing and so
you stop paying attention to those
details that inevitably will one day get
you and and could potentially put you at
risk for it for an infection if you look
at the other side so that's over
behavior but if you look at the other
side where you're under behaving then we
run the risk of not being prepared to do
the job that you need to do and it also
you know your recall capabilities so say
for example you average of one spill per
year or maybe two or three the point is
is those aren't high frequency events
and if you're not trained on an annual
basis you may forget how to say evacuate
a laboratory during an emergency
response or catch an animal that has
escaped or maybe a spill that has
occurred on the ground or a cut that
occurs as a result of necropsy if you're
not trained annually then your
capability to respond to those
situations will be minimized and so when
you look at training and the benefit of
training you've really got to make sure
that training not only attacks
complacency and the sense of falling
into a routine that cannot be changed
but it also addresses issues of low
frequency events so that when you you
find yourself in these situations an
annual training program will remind
folks of what to do in these low
frequent low frequency type situations
okay another thing that that trainers
must become aware of is this concept of
behavioral evolution and what do I mean
by that if you look at this it's the
cycle and if you if you're a behavioral
based meaning if you're interested in
learning about behavioral based training
aspects get ready this is this gonna
kind of talk to you a little bit about
those if you look at the far left you'll
see this increased awareness that's the
level of green that's kind of where we
want people to be that's the first time
you ever got on a bike for example the
first time you ever drove a car your
hands were attending to your eyes were
wide open you were paying attention to
everything around you
music even was a distractor okay when
you're practicing a new behavior you
have an increased level of awareness
which is where we want you to be at all
times but unfortunately as you continue
to do that behavior so as you drove more
on that bike or on that car you began to
play your music answer text messages
voicemails you began doing things other
than driving because you got comfortable
and that's what we call this perceived
mastery you believed I have the behavior
down so this may be when you're changing
cages or you're doing certain animal
husbandry aspects you're not paying
attention to details because you've got
this behavior down and you're in what we
call a ritual a habit the problem with
that is you're now at a decreased
attention level decrease the tension
level to the details and you're at risk
for an incident or an accident and
sooner or later that incident or an
accident happen now it may not happen to
you this is the cool part you know we
can live vicariously through people so
if it happens to somebody and we hear
about it we can learn from it and as a
result make sure that we prevent it from
happening within our own organizations
but if you don't learn from someone else
then the accident or incident happens
and that's where we're in this red area
now the range of consequence for
laboratory accident is quite serious you
could have a near-miss you can have an
incident that causes little to no damage
you can't have an incident an accident
causes a serious injury and you can have
an incident an accident causes an injury
either kills you or even hurt someone
else the reality is is that the range of
consequence is huge so when you look at
where we would intervene first as a
trainer we would intervene right after
some new folks start working and they've
worked for about three to four months
man I would inundate them with training
and I would put challenges in front of
them that would challenge their
confidence and make sure that they
understand that it's not you know their
routine is a great routine for them but
they have to continue to pay attention
to detail so right at the the the
you know the the mark between proceed
mastery and the incident you're gonna
want to inject some type of behavioral
based training now after an incident as
Frederick Nietzsche says look if it
doesn't kill you to make you stronger
you know make mistakes because you learn
from them you change hopefully you do
and as a result of this change you go to
an increased level of awareness yet
again but this time because of all your
experience you're at a new level of
mastery so you're not where you were
when you first started the behavior
you're actually at an increased
awareness state after mastering the
behavior for quite some time it's right
here between this mastery and
complacency that the second round of
training should occur meaning folks who
have been doing this job for years five
six seven years this is about the time
when the next major accident begins to
happen to them and that's as a result of
complacency once they become complacent
again they go back into the incident
near-miss and the cycle continues it's
infinity and this is kind of how we as
individuals grow and learn through life
this concept of behavioral evolution
gives us an idea as trainers in
understanding what training can be used
for not only to make sure that people
are doing what it is they're supposed to
be doing when they set out early in
their careers but when folks become
complacent later in their careers in
that was complacency as well the next
slide is I have to give Prochaska the
credit for this he talks about how
people learn and as trainers it's very
very important that we set our our
learners up in actually you know in
actuality to learn and so what do I mean
by that most people that come to a
training program and I'd say there are
several folks out there listening to me
right now some of you may be sleeping or
doing whatever but some of you are
listening most folks that come to a
training unfortunately don't come to
learn I wish that when I looked out into
the eyes of the audience and all the
classes that I've ever taught I see a
bunch of
who are just soaking up every single
word I say those individuals are very
few a small small group of folks that
actually operate that way they actually
come to a training program to really
truly learn majority of folks come to a
training program to evaluate what the
trainer is saying yeah you know you'll
see it in the ayats makes sense yes yes
I agree with that no no I don't really
agree with that and they began
evaluating and and taking a look at what
the individual is saying based on their
own experiences and based on their you
know their you know their own education
levels and that's okay the third aspect
you see is people who actually come to a
training program to teach so they they
use the training program to actually
teach others even though they're not
necessarily the teacher or the trainer
what we want you to do as trainers is to
prepare the learner and what that means
is is that whole thing if you exalt
yourself you will be humbled but if you
humble yourself you will be exalted what
we want folks to do as learners is we
want to put them in a position where
they realize that there is something to
be learned in the class so what I like
to do is I like to give folks a test at
the beginning of every class that I
teach I give them an exam the exam has
questions that quite honestly are almost
impossible for them to answer regardless
of their level of experience because
again that's what this training program
is going to address it's going to give
them the answers to that test but when
they take that test initially you see
some type of event occur with them they
they become disappointed in themselves
they realize that maybe there is
something for them to learn and the
minute a learner realizes that you're
converting your class to more of a
sponge-like class meaning they are now
seasoned to receive the information that
you're about ready to give them meaning
don't ever have somebody come in and
just assume they want to learn the
reality is is we've got to start setting
the stage for learning to occur so if
you look at this theory that for Chaska
talks about he basically say
when we talk about behavior people will
always believe in a greater percentage
of six you know they can do something
that they really can't all of you out
there who are wondering what I mean by
this just go out to your garage and take
a look at bikes that you once my saying
that I will you know use this all the
time
weight sets fishing poles kayaks even
gym memberships that you bought and you
used once and don't use the rest of the
year what he calls this as unconscious
incompetence which means I believe I'm
capable of doing something I believe it
with all my heart and then when I go to
do it and I learned that I can't I
become what I call conscious incompetent
meaning I am now aware of what it is
that I don't know so if I had a puzzle
some of you have seen the exercise that
I that I do I have an Elizabeth or
Griffin puzzle and I had this puzzle and
I asked people what's the likelihood
that you'd put this puzzle together in
one minute or less if you're a man
typically you save 50 percent if you're
a woman you save 30% but after one
minute of trying that majority of folks
will say zero percent that is a transfer
from what we call unconscious
incompetence to conscious incompetence
and that's a good start so now
someone is ready to learn they know they
can't do it so now we're going to teach
them okay and they're listening now we
teach them the SOP three times the first
time we have them watch what we do the
second time we have them tell us what we
should do and then the third time we
have them demonstrate what we expected
them to do and after that we ask him on
a scale of zero to hundred percent what
the likelihood is that they can do this
SOP typically after those three times an
individual will say a hundred percent
and that's not a good answer
it's not a good answer because that
individual has now but are now believes
that their success is determined on only
their skill and the reality is as folks
have to understand that it's not just
about their skill it's about the
resources they have access to the
environments that they're working in
that there could be all sorts of
fluctuations that are going to be to
turn
of their success if the individual says
Shawn I can put this puzzle together one
minute or less with that SOP I then tell
them to close their eyes and once they
close their eyes they no longer can do
it in one minute or less and at that
point I have them open their eyes after
they try and I say on a scale of zero to
hundred percent zero being unlikely I
know percent being very likely what's
the likely that you'll be able to put
this puzzle together in one minute or
less if they look at me and they say
Shawn well I have my eyes open well I
have all the pieces of the puzzle in
front of me at that point I now know
that they've entered what we call
conscious confidence which is they
realize that it's not just about their
skill but it's about having everything
they need to do what is expected of them
so I think that as trainers we must
prepare our learners we can't assume
that folks that come to us in a training
class are there to learn we have to in
essence season them and prep them for
the training program that we're about to
deliver now this is a picture of my
family and it's kind of a cool picture
I'm trying to to see if I can use an
arrow here I believe I will if you look
up here at the at the top part here what
you're going to see is a bunch of
novices and what do I mean by novices as
trainers we have to realize that not
everybody who comes to our training
program is at the same level of all of
you out there and there's quite a bit of
you I know that some of you are
brand-new trainers some of you are just
getting started in your career some of
you have been in your career for 10 to
15 years and some of you have been in
your career for 20-25 years
the reality is is that not all training
programs should be designed for one
particular audience novices are
individuals that really in essence want
to know why and these are the awareness
aspects so if you can imagine your
children they want to know why do I have
to go to bed why do I have to take a
shower why do I have to look both ways
when I cross the street a novice is
always in the pursuit of understanding
why things
why am i doing what it is that I'm doing
now if you look at the next level here
the next level of groups are what we
call practitioners so these are the
practitioners the parents of the
children these parents and these
practitioners are really innocent
skill-based they want to know how how do
I do this how do I get my kid to take a
shower
every night how do I get my child to
stay seated in in their chairs how do I
get my child so they are looking at
skill practitioners want skill and they
are looking for skill skill aspects and
how to do a particular behavior now one
of the most neglected groups out there
and we see it in biosafety all the time
because people say well I've just got
this p.i that is just so resistant to
change the reality is experts need
training to these experts are
individuals who have a wealth of
experience and if they do not have
training that teaches them to transfer
that wealth of information without
putting on practitioners or novices if
they don't have training to do that then
their lessons that they've learned may
be lost and lost forever so the reality
is is when you look at the the the
audiences that you are addressing
remember that there are people that are
looking for information specific to why
there are people looking for information
specific to how and then there are
people looking for information specific
to win and where do i plug this
information in so that I don't lose the
practitioners and the novices now as a
side note I want to you know I want to
talk a little bit about this concept I
have over here this this aspect I think
it is very very important because
novices have a tremendous amount of
learning to do and typically they learn
through mentoring from practitioners at
least I hope they do but I want to
stress the fact that novices can teach
practitioners a lot too
they can teach practitioners how to
become better experts by teaching them
communication skills and team-building
skills and patience and mentoring skills
all which are very very needed at the
expert level and I and I continue on
with the fact that experts have to have
dialogue with practitioners but
practitioners can teach experts as well
so any expert out there that is still
mouths pipetting if you go to a
practitioner chances are they can teach
you how not the mouth pipet alternative
behaviors if you're smelling a petri
dishes are doing things in outdated ways
practitioners can help but experts in
turn can also help with the the wealth
of experience and that they have last
but not least and I think very very
important is this concept right here
experts and novices must have dialogue
novices today have a tremendous amount
of technological
they have the capability of doing things
that that that folks entering the
workforce many years ago we're not
capable of doing experts can be mentored
by novices and attics that exchange of
novice and and an expert is priceless
and and just to put it in simple terms
look there is no doubt that the children
learn a tremendous amount from parents
but there's also no doubt that I as a
parent have learned a tremendous amount
from the children I raise my dad and my
mom had taught me a tremendous amount
and I know that I have taught them a
tremendous amount - this is post me
being a child I also know that in the
summers that my kids spend with my mom
and dad their grandparents that my mom
and dad continue to learn a tremendous
amount about themselves even through
their grandchildren so if you use this
sense of family in the laboratory
environment in a sense of level of
learners you'll see that there are
valuable lessons to be learned across
all gamuts and all levels of learners
okay
the next slide and is one of my favorite
mentors I saw him do a presentation when
I was going through school and he was
the reason why I wanted to become a
teacher but it was Jaime Escalante Jaime
Escalante was responsible for teaching
those kids calculus out in Los Angeles
the kids that nobody believed in the
kids that everybody gave up on and Jaime
Escalante Dearing has taught many years
ago said to me Sean not me but to the
audience and you know I took it personal
here but he said look students will
always rise to the level of expectation
don't be afraid of pushing them too hard
in fact be afraid of not pushing them
hard enough and I will tell you that
almost every training program I have
ever constructed or built has always
been designed to push people out of
their comfort zone to push them beyond
what they think they can do their
capabilities and the reality is is that
very very very rarely do people fail in
fact they learn a lot more and if you
think about all the teachers that have
the greatest impact on you usually those
teachers were not the ones that made you
feel the most comfortable they were the
ones that showed you that you were much
more than you thought you were so Jaime
Escalante reminds us as teachers and as
trainers look if you're not
uncomfortable learning new behavior then
something's wrong the first time you got
on that bike as exciting as it was to
see the bike in the garage as exciting
as it was to wait for a non rainy day
the minute you sat on that bike and look
down that road and started a pedal you
were scared same goes with driving you
were scared
any new behavior you're doing is going
to cause some type of nervousness and
that's normal and if you feel that in a
training program you know you're doing
training because you're building skill
and that's important push people out of
their comfort zone be there by their
side mentor them so that they learn new
skills and they learn what they need to
be successful in the job that they're
doing stop doing PowerPoint don't waste
time
to give someone a PowerPoint
presentation on how to ride a bike
before they ride a bike is useless
Einstein said that Einstein said
education before
experience is a waste you're wasting
time trying to teach somebody how to
change cages with a PowerPoint it just
throw them in the lab with you have them
watch how to change cages have them
demonstrate with you how to change cages
and then if you want to show them the
PowerPoint on changing cages bring them
back in the classroom to show them that
and that will allow them to fine tune
their behaviors but don't start with
PowerPoint get their hands dirty get
them behaving right away let them start
training immediately and then focus on
building that overall awareness now one
other issue in training is this concept
that people are trained and I and I
can't stand that I can't stand that to
me that word is a cuss word trained
means my investment in you is done
that's what trained means and let me
tell you when trained ends trained ends
the moment the training program ceases
and what I mean by that is if someone
has passed a training program the
retention and the ability to recall all
that is learned in the training begins
to fade and fade quickly and we know
this firsthand with what we've seen at
Emory and with the courses that we've
taught I've had several repeat students
who will take the course as many years
later and the retention is is at a level
that it once was when we first started
working together I would like trainers
to look at themselves as someone like a
dimmer switch a repeated inject meaning
we are going to professionally and
personally develop the individual on a
frequent basis with small doses we're
not going to flick a switch and then
flick it off so trained untrained
trained untrained
no rather we're going to develop an
individual slowly so it's almost two
steps forward one step back two steps
forward one step back but they never go
back to where they were before as a
result of that repeated inject aspect so
when we train folks don't develop
training programs where you say I've
trained and they're trained and we're
done rather develop programs that we
allow you to
have repeated injects repeated reminders
bite-sized pieces you know an apple
taste great and bite-sized pieces but if
you ran the whole Apple down someone's
throat it doesn't taste like an apple at
all
so give folks bite-sized pieces and be
fine and creative I mean if you want to
increase laboratory awareness go into a
lab and blindfold someone of course you
know they're not doing something risky
but blindfold them and say that they've
got something in their eye and they've
got to wash their eye out and find the
sink and find the eye wash station let
them wander blindfolded let them do it
for three minutes if they pass great if
they don't great it's not it's not about
pass or fail what it's about is the
minute that blindfold comes off their
attention to detail in that laboratory
environment will increase they will pay
attention to where things are and where
the sink is and where the eye wash
station is and that for that profound
impact from just a three to four minute
intervention is far greater than the
impact it would have 60 minutes in a
PowerPoint presentation so be creative
and have fun and challenge people
training is supposed to be fun it's
supposed to be challenging it's not
supposed to be something that puts
people to sleep so consider that when
did when when delivering your training
programs also consider this don't use
SOPs to train people in fact I'm going
to challenge everyone out there to be
SOP free when training look SOPs are for
regulators folks they're for the folks
that want to know what you're doing in
the lab they're also performance
indicators meaning you're going to take
an SOP and know exactly what you expect
of your staff in that laboratory
environment and that is what an SOP is
for it is not designed to be for
training it is not designed to train an
individual it is designed however to
verify that an individual has
successfully completed a training that
is what an SOP can do meaning if you
take the SOP out you look at it and you
watch the behavior that someone is doing
someone who has been through a training
program
you're watching it and their behavior
matches that which is written on the SOP
the person has successfully completed
the training that is what an SOP is for
if you're giving people SOPs in training
it's like me giving the key to a test to
a student in a class and then when they
take the test and pass I say look what
they know it's awesome they're ready
they can do it giving someone the key to
the test giving someone an SOP to guide
their behaviors and then say that they
are verified and that they have been
trained and that they are ready to work
in a lab is cheating
instead take the SOP ask them to
demonstrate the behavior if the behavior
matches the SOP they've been verified
and are able to go work in the
laboratory environment trainers must
also make sure that you guys have the
take your take your time not take your
time but that you understand how much
time you have one of the very first
questions that I ask when folks say
Shawn can you develop a training program
for us I'll say well how much time do I
have and how many people am I going to
be training that gives me an idea of
what I can do unfortunately a majority
of training programs out there today if
you look at it you take 52 weeks and you
divide it by four weeks off of vacation
two weeks on holidays it gives us 46
weeks of work forty hours a week is this
about 1800 hours and if you look at
training at 1% that's roughly about 18
hours of training or about 2 days of
training per year and that right there
I'll be honest with you is about
industry standard and that is well below
what any industry who works like for
example airplane pilots firefighters
police officers military personnel
anyone who works in a risky situation
that puts their lives at risk
trained far more than 1% of their time
on the job in this in this in this
capacity so if you have a laboratory
staff and animal care animal animal
staff specifically your training
percentage should fall anywhere between
3 to 5 percent and that 3 to 5% is going
to give you roughly about a week
training per year and that is going to
allow for organizations to see the
benefit of training meaning the repeated
injects of their staff I know out there
there are folks that are saying there's
no way we can take care of the animals
and do what we're doing and do how we're
doing if we're gonna spend a lot of time
training I can't we can't do that our
job is 365 days of the year 24 hours a
day and I understand that and I get that
but that doesn't minimize your risk in
fact that increases your risk and that
excuse that you have is a reason that
that that should got or that should
promote more training rather than push
training away so that reason that you
that that's out there that we work
constantly that we're always working
that we have no time
those that type of situation increases
your overall risk at work and that
excuse right there is the reason to get
training rather than run away from that
overall training aspect and don't get me
wrong I have to say majority of the
training that I've seen out there is
very boring and puts a lot of people to
sleep and the reality of the situation
is training has to be hands-on engaging
and something that makes folks want to
be there rather than something that
makes folks want to go to sleep or even
want to get back to their job so the
reality is is that trainers have to know
how much time they're working with so
that they have the capability of putting
in the learning objectives that they
need to accomplish now real quick I put
this in the slide set for for trainers
so that you you know if you're writing
learning objectives you're writing
measurable learning objectives if you
look at these these verbs these verbs
are measurable and quite honestly these
are the verbs that you want to use when
you write your tests so for example if
I'm creating a test for a novice I'm
going to ask a novice to describe or to
define it's a sight to recall to
recognize to select these are verbs that
will demonstrate a general awareness
about a particular topic if I'm going to
test the practitioner then I'm going to
use distinguish differentiate describe
demonstrate these are verbs that we
would use for
or practitioners where they would have
the opportunity to show or behave in a
particular manner and when we get to
application or expert aspects and I'm so
sorry I have to tell you right now I'm
looking at this slide and it is an EIR
and I apologize if you look at these
comprehension verbs and you look at
these application verbs there are
flip-flopped the application verbs are
actually the practitioner verbs so the
ability to apply calculate complete
demonstrate those are practitioner
because they're focused on skill if you
look at comprehension
that's expert and so these are folks
that can distinguish estimate explained
because it takes not only experience but
it takes time to improve those abilities
to do that so again I apologize for the
air on the slide this is a big air and I
do apologize I'll make kind of a little
note on on this as well here but what
I'd like to do again reference is that
this is here and then this is up here as
well so again forgive me for making that
mistake and I apologize for not catching
that sooner now last but not least
before we open it up for questions and I
really do hope that the folks stick
around for questions and and have some
questions but last but not least you
know we have to as trainers be able to
evaluate our programs because when
you're training you tend to have this
emotional connection and everybody you
know everybody's gonna they're not going
to believe what you think or what you
feel about your overall training program
so you've got to have the results
demonstrate your work for you so you're
gonna want to evaluate the participant
and that's not what the participant
likes or thinks that's where the
participants cognitive and practical
abilities are during the beginning of
the class then you measure the process
which is a day to day evaluation that
lets you know how the students feel or
how the participants feel about your
course and also lets you know any any
knowledge and and practical
experience has been gained as a result
of course you grade your instructors so
that your instructors know how
successful they are not only in and how
well they're received by the students
but also how well the students received
information from them and then last but
not least your post assessment of the
participant will demonstrate benefit
gained so as a trainer if you're not
evaluating your programs and you're just
assuming that your programs are working
well please think again always evaluate
your program so that when the time comes
to fight for your program or suggest
that you do more of your program the
people that you're fighting for the
voices that you're showing and giving a
justification from it's not just you
it's hey look at the hundreds of people
I trained look at what they're saying
and these are the people that are gonna
be let down if we do not train anymore
or we don't have this training program
okay
now the last statement is kind of a neat
one working at Emory and owning a
business has really opened my eyes
there's no doubt in my mind that I would
have loved to have had each and every
one of you in this session right now
with me so that I could see your faces I
could I could see the the strange looks
that you would have I could see the the
things that you would disagree with the
things that you would agree with I could
have an open dialogue I could use you in
front of the class
as an example but the reality is this
that way of delivering a talk is is in
my opinion the best way but it is not
the most practical and these days is
going to become far and few much fewer
in between because travel budgets and
all sorts of things the reality is is
that I would always prefer a training to
occur in in person especially if it's a
skill based training however there are
some really really cool programs out
there like YouTube or other programs out
there that will teach you a skill with a
video of a particular video interactive
type piece so through your computer you
can learn a particular skill I know it's
weird but
you know we as human beings if we watch
a particular behavior we can absorb it
we can learn it we can learn new things
and the reality is is that through
computers or what we would call you know
elearning systems online learning
systems we can teach particular
behaviors especially if we're very
specific about what we're looking for we
can teach SOPs by showing them over and
over and over again then it's simply
asking people to demonstrate them upon
completion of the training but the last
one is the most intriguing the last one
is a symbol of go to training or go to
meeting but we have a good - training
platform or any platform like the one
we're using right now this is a
phenomenal opportunity an opportunity to
go through a training program and have a
live instructor be able to answer
questions be able to facilitate
discussion be able to interact with the
audience allowing all of you to be where
you are right now whether it be in the
office at home some of you may be in
cars you could be all over the world
literally and you still have access to a
trainer it's it's kind of the the the
middle ground between an online course
and an in-person course and I think
these courses are going to be offered a
lot more I know we're offering them a
lot more I think a lot of folks are
offering a lot more and they're
different than webinars webinars don't
allow for a lot of interaction these
platforms that are now coming out allow
for a significant amount of interaction
between the instructor and the
participant and I think that you're
gonna see a lot more of those and I
would strongly suggest that Emory for
example we are doing these training
programs now using this platform for our
own internal audience so when we do
blood-borne pathogen training or any
type of in-person training we now are
having facilitators allow people to
train remotely so that we can get larger
audiences saving a lot of resources but
delivering a high quality product at the
same time so I guess at this time I'm
looking for any questions that you may
have and I guess Tracy you're gonna
facilitate that but I appreciate all of
you
attending and taking the time to be here
in Atlanta with me and should you have
any questions that that are not answered
in this presentation I've both my web
address and my personal email and cell
phone number please feel free to give me
a call I'd be very very happy to answer
any questions you may have
Tracy
maybe not Tracy I'm gonna see let's see
if I can do the Q&A session so far I
only have one question folks from it
looks like Russell and says Sean how do
you suggest dealing with single
individual how do you suggest dealing
with single individuals with persistent
infractions that's oh that's a
million-dollar question
Russell very good okay so the first
question or the first thing that we've
got to do is we've got to give them
expectations and I want to kind of
cruise it through this because
expectations in the laboratory
environment are very very important so
we call these behavioral expectations
I'm will list the top five and get ready
guys if you're if you're getting ready
to leave don't leave on this one because
the top five I think are very very
important the first expectation is we
will follow all SOPs to the best of my
to the best of our ability the second
the expectation is we will fall or we
will ensure others around us follow SOPs
to the best of their ability now those
two expectations come from a lesson
learned with Beth Griffin and the ocular
exposure to herpes B virus she got
something in her eye she knew the SOP
was to flush her eye out the colleague
that she was with also knew that she had
got something awry and had a chance to
really motivate Beth to go flush her eye
out nothing like that happened and the
reality is is that you know policies and
procedures cannot be enforced by
biosafety officers because we're not
going to ever have the resources to do
that so it has to be self governed so we
have to not only make sure we agree to
follow SOPs but that others around us
follow the SOPs as well this
the third behavioral expectation is that
we're going to report any laboratory
accidents or incidents allowing for the
organization to improve as a result of
the lesson that we may have learned
remember if we don't report an accident
or incident then we don't have an
opportunity to improve and the lesson
the lesson for the organization is lost
the fourth expectation is I will report
any symptoms which match the clinical
presentation of the pathogens that I'm
working with this helps with medical
surveillance and ensuring that if people
do get sick as a result of laboratory
acquired illness they get treatment and
it is discovered immediately the last
behavioral expectation is I will report
any new medical conditions that may
include medications that cause seizures
pregnancy diabetes chronic asthmatic
conditions where I take steroids and
that may weaken my immune system these
things people like to claim are
protected under HIPAA but the reality is
if you're working in a lab with
infectious pathogens and you have any
one of these conditions you'd better
report them so that we have an
opportunity to protect them I'd go back
to the laboratory accidents and
incidents and the death at UCLA and how
that that event had occurred and how it
occurred prior and nobody did anything
about it and it led to a death of a
young lady and a chem lab if you look at
the the lack of medical surveillance at
Boston University with the pneumonic
tool Aranea cases where three people got
sick while working with a contaminated
strain of tularemia and the last but not
least the death that occurred at
University of Chicago in Illinois from
an individual who was working with your
Senia pestis died from pneumonic plague
as a result of a compromised immune
system and an iron disorder so to answer
your question again and I apologize for
being so long-winded we have to first
make sure Russell that that the
individual has expectations live up to
after we have those expectations have
been clear we then will meet with the
individual when there's an infraction if
that infraction occurs we then ask them
well you know do you understand the risk
you understand the benefit do you have
the resources do you have the skills did
straight down do you have the
self-advocacy and believe so we make
sure that they have the find things they
need to behave and then if they do it
again
we make sure that they are escorted in
the lab by somebody who we would call as
in green standing now what what does
that mean escorted adults hate and they
absolutely do not like being escorted by
and by other individuals but the reality
is is that anytime we punish someone for
not following the rules we're removing
them from ever gaining benefit or ever
having to practice this give you a
classic example when I was a kid i stunk
it doing dishes I and I did it on
purpose and one night my mom really saw
this and she talked to my dad my dad
walked off and I thought I was
successful in this he came back about a
half an hour later and he he thanked me
for my efforts with the dishes and then
he said son as you know I'm not very
happy I said yeah I played along he says
so I went around to all the neighbors
and tonight he will be doing all of
their dishes only to come back here and
do these dishes again because I want to
make sure that you're successful at
doing these dishes what my dad did and
that moment was teach me that the only
way I'm ever going to get out of doing
something as if I do a right number one
but he also allowed me to practice the
skills that I wasn't so good at so
punishing people by removing them from
the lab is not the solution if they are
messing up you make them do the behavior
over and over and over and over and over
again until they get it right and that
is how I deal with somebody who was
persistently messing up I hope that
answers your your question the next
question comes from and gosh Mike I
can't say your name Nicola from Chile so
this is really cool very very very very
cool to see if you like let's see here
it says learn anything like listen this
in two hours
great III don't know if that's a
question let's see here
thank you very much for responding I'm
having a little difficulty here any
other questions out there I don't see
any other any other questions out there
and what
during Roman said and I don't see
anybody else come on there has to be
some more you got to give me a little
bit more all right let's see here okay
well I guess that being said I know
there's still quite a bit of folks
online again if you have any questions
any questions that you that you have for
me my email my phone number is available
I appreciate all the kind compliments
you guys are sending thank you very very
much for sending those Stephanie God and
I appreciate that and oh it looks like
we do have a question if you have a PI
who has a bad lab practice how do you
handle that bad lab practice you know I
would you know I'd focus on the P I
primarily and I know this is going to
sound callous but this is what I do know
Cowboys are Cowboys and sometimes
Cowboys don't realize that it's not just
about them it's about the agency it's
about the organization it's about the
research it's about the their family
it's about everything outside of them
and so I would again with those remember
we talked earlier about the five things
that people need to behave I would again
have a discussion of the risk but from a
very unique perspective I would ask them
what the risk is and they're gonna sit
back and say I know the risk I'm you
know I said no I want to know what the
risk is to the organization to the
research agenda to the animals to our
reputation should what you're doing have
a profound impact on something and get
them to think outside of themselves and
as you get them to think outside of
themselves they may begin to see the
need
the validity behind changing a
particular behavior I have to tell you
as a trainer the hardest group of people
to change to change our experts the
hardest people to train our
practitioners and so when you look at
changing API that has years and years
and years and years of experience I by
no means think that's a simple process
but I will tell you this get them
thinking about the risk outside of
themselves it's not just about them it's
about their other lab folks it's about
the research agenda it's about the
animals it's about the reputation of the
organization and get them thinking about
a common cause as to why we're behaving
in a consistent manner rather than the
way they're choosing to behave any other
questions out there comments any it says
any suggestions any ideas or suggestions
about changing your overall health and
safety culture in a positive and fun way
with activities absolutely Shelly thank
you for asking that I and from the
National Research Council I do a lot of
training and safety culture I was just
actually in New Zealand at a keynote
address for New Zealand out there at
safety culture and we did actually a
lunch break series recently on safety
culture I think the the biggest
influencer of safety culture in my
opinion is this concept of intrinsic
safety and what I mean by that is if you
were to to to view safety as a service
industry we are going to serve folks
we're not going to police folks we're
going to serve them and what I mean by
serving is we're not going to do safety
for them and to them we're going to do
that with them and by them so that by
the time we leave them we've increased
their capacity and their capability to
actually do safety and so the reality is
is a concept of intrinsic safety means
that we're going to view every single
person is creative capable and complete
enough to develop safety solutions for
them and as a safety officer we're going
to review those safety solutions we're
not going to do safety for them
not going to do it to them we're gonna
do it with them in the trenches so that
by the time we leave safety is something
that they own and safety is something
that they're comfortable with the
problem with safety today
is a lot of safety officers are
separating themselves from the science
and a lot of scientists are separating
themselves from safety and when you do
that the lens is that those individuals
who look through become a lot more
distant because of that siloed effect we
have to stop looking through different
lenses and the only way we have we can
do that is if scientists start working
with safety professionals and safety
professionals start working with
scientists and we get them engaged
actively in safety with an intrinsic
model and I'd be very happy to elaborate
more on that later with you if if you
would like any other questions or
comments folks these questions are great
I appreciate them any other questions
going once going twice okay I think we
are about ready to end the session again
thank you all very very much and so long
from Atlanta I think we're good thank
you very much